his spot in the rotation might be on the
line last time out he would stick to
that seven nothing lead let it get away
uh did not make it through two winning
so you know he really wants to step up
big here tonight for the season a big
jake is five and eight with a five point
five seven era jake garrieta who is
ready to go and the first pitch is lying
to left field and that's in for a base
hit a one hop off the wall and into the
ivy
i mean smoked into the ivy yeah that one
ain't coming out no
inside it hits jt so the phillies have
runners on first and second
with nobody out and bryce harper is
coming up
2-0 to harper
and harper hits it sharply through the
hole on the right side into right field
they're going to hold up segura hayward
does have a gold glove
in right field so the bases are now
loaded for andrew mccutchen
2-1 pitch
a high fly ball to center field carrying
fairly well half is back to the wall
it's a grand slam for andrew mccutchen
the wind is blowing out and that one
carried right over the basket and into
the second row it's four-nothing
phillies
noah he's the one who's in charge of it
this is his 18th start a 4.44 era
playing the pull on the right side a
little bit
and he shoots it right at sigour who
doesn't even have to move to field the
ground ball
that is a comfortable seven-pitch
hitting
for aaron nolan
score on this
base hit by sedora
does line it into left field to base hit
and it's kicked by peterson jankowski
would not have scored now he drops it
and into second is segora it's five
nothing phillies
[Music]
and we'll wait and see how the official
score scores that
but jankowski froze for a moment because
it was a line drive
shot the other way that's a fair ball
into left field segura is held up again
the bases are loaded for
and mccutcheon just turns and walks
back to the jungle so he gets him
looking fourth strikeout for jake
oskin struck out his first time up two
oh [ __ ] covered
that one's out towards center field it's
not deep running it is half still coming
in he dives and he dropped it
two runs will score
as hoskins goes to second he's safe at
second
it's 7-0 phillies
that's ripped and a base hit right field
alcantara
as harper collects and throws it in
[Applause]
that one in the year right field and
it'll fall for a hit alcantara
will advance or take a little bloop
single two on and nobody out yeah
something for the fans to get fired up
about here
so two aboard and now here's jack
[Applause]
harper all the way to the wall
and or take a big turn
that will stay put
cubs on the board
jock with a rocket rbi double
left field base hit mccutchen will
collect
in to score ortega bryant with an rbi
single and it's 7-2
[Applause]
reaches out hits it in the air out
towards center field jankowski
tagging from third and scoring his job
and it's 7-3
and off the glove
of alcantara into center field
segura was not running as soon as he hit
it but he is at first
that one is hit toward right that's a
fair ball going to the corner segura
will score
moving it got stuck in the ivy and
they're going to tell rio muto he's
gonna have to go back to third base
it's gonna be a double for harper
the phillies lead it
eight to three
it could have been a two-run double
but the ivy took it away
out to right field
and it's right at hayward tagging it
third is real butoh here he comes the
throw by hayward is up the line it's a
sacrifice fly
reece has three runs batted in it's nine
to three phillies
and we
will honor and celebrate the anthony
rizzo family foundation he also received
his fourth gold glove he ties mark grace
for the most by a cubs first baseman and
then javi baez got his first and he
became the first cubs shortstop in 50
years to win a gold glove so special
night for both of them we know javi
loves to keep all of his accolades so
i'm sure that's going to have a nice
place back in his home in florida guys
towards left center forget it
[Applause]
heading overs again tonight leads the
team number 20 for javi
yep
fly ball left field it's deep and it is
long gone
wow
that hit off the scoreboard i think it
did reece hoskins his 20th home run of
the year he has 53 runs batted in that's
where it hit
and the phillies are on top 10 to four
rips it into left field to base it one
run is it here comes jankowski he's
going to score the throw goes to third
it's a two-run single for segura and the
hits just keep on coming for the fills
bryce harper crushes one out toward
right field winkler looking back and it
is gone
so much for that rbi on the road thing a
three-run home run and he is exploding
with rudders in scoring position tonight
it's a
non-solo home run for bryce
it's only a matter of time
15-4 phillies
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
see
in the year center field well struck you
can't forget it
second of the night for javi
[Music]
number 21
[Music]
racing and they're going to send it when
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
bryce tonight has homer doubled and
singled twice
and hits this one for another big
sentence to center fields
going to third is luke williams
it's a five hit night for bryce
it's a beautiful thing didn't he have a
five-hit game of colorado last year or
two years ago
remember he hit a bunch of balls up the
middle left center field
he's staying on ball so good right now
that is a
beautiful thing for mr harper yep april
19th 2019 against colorado he was five
for seven with two doubles and an rvi so
it's only his second
oh that's drilled to center look out
welcome to the cubs robinson torinos
i guess maybe i should say welcome back
his first
pro organization as he goes yard
[Applause]
[Music]
swing gonna miss and that is the ball
game the phillies have handed the cubs
another loss
it's 15 to 10 the final score